[Música]
en afganistán los talibanes aseguraron
que habrá que esperar un tiempo para la
fecha oficial de la conformación de
gobierno sin embargo las consultas entre
las filas del nuevo régimen se
aceleraron después de la salida
definitiva de las tropas estadounidenses
tenemos reportes desde kabul con el
enviado especial sin vayan
ataque terrorista en nueva zelanda deja
al menos 6 heridos con arma blanca y al
presunto autor sin vida según la policía
el atacante actuó solo la primera
ministra hasina arena aseguró que el
hombre era un ciudadano decir blanca que
llegó al país en el año 2011 y estaba en
la lista de terroristas tenemos reporte
desde australia
a edad que como huracán generó una gran
devastación en el sur de eeuu y luego se
convirtió en un ciclón tropical azotó en
las últimas horas varios estados del
noreste del país dejando al menos 44
fallecidos debido a las lluvias
torrenciales rápidas inundaciones y
vientos huracanados
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en france 24 blanco como siempre permite
es un gusto saludarlos comenzamos en
afganistán donde los talibanes
aseguraron que el anuncio del nuevo
gobierno aún tendrá que esperar un
tiempo después de que se especulara que
el acto podría ser hoy luego de los
restos del viernes sin embargo el
portavoz talibán bilal carini reconoció
que las consultas entre las filas de los
talibanes y políticos afganos sobre la
formación de este nuevo gobierno el
nuevo sistema islámico que regirá en el
país han concluido por su parte china
que ha criticado lo que considera una
apresurada y mal planificada retirada de
eeuu de afganistán se ha mostrado
dispuesta a entablar relaciones
amistosas y cooperativas con el nuevo
régimen y su embajada en kabul y
cooperativa nuestro enviado especial a
cabo y zilli payán con todos los
detalles donde ondean de perspectiva de
cantidades de baby baby jane y people
bajo la perspectiva canales puedo decir
que en las calles de kabul mucha gente
es bastante escéptica sobre las promesas
que los talibanes han estado haciendo
durante las últimas semanas dirigía
sobre todo a la comunidad internacional
in plain we could 6 foto past weeks
como sabrán afganistán está muy cerca de
un colapso económico y es extremadamente
dependiente de los miles de millones de
dólares que podrían llegar al país
provenientes de la comunidad
internacional william sedales whitcomb
from the international community show
crimen estuviese en the afghan tipo de
bilibid very much maybe así que queda
mucho por ver los afganos no tienen
demasiada fe quizás porque siguen
traumatizados por el periodo de reinado
del terror de los aviones entre 1996 y
sin embargo lo que es muy importante hoy
viernes que aquí es como un domingo es
que las calles están bastante vacías así
que podríamos esperar el anuncio de este
nuevo gobierno inclusivo o no para el
final del día después de la gran oración
trier
[Música]
uy uy uy uy uy uy uy tenchu a donde esté
andando y dónde talibán comiendo la
cuestión es que tenemos que entender que
los comandos talibanes se están moviendo
rápido para la comunidad internacional
pero también para los afganos porque la
gente en afganistán ya especialmente en
la capital kabul no es la misma que en
1996 han pasado 20 años de emancipación
alfabetización y podemos percibir que no
están contentos al dirigirse hacia un
futuro incierto hay muchas preguntas sin
respuestas pero la primera respuesta
debería ser dinero en efectivo podemos
ver mucha gente haciendo colas para
obtener unos cuantos dólares un poco de
dinero principalmente para la comida en
ciudades recién hace un manifiesto
kuwait surf administration's las
instituciones las administraciones están
todas cerradas los talibanes lo saben
esta es la razón por la que necesitan
avanzar a corto plazo y presentar su
nuevo gobierno del nuevo emirato
islámico de afganistán los días new
islámica y berto afganistán cambiamos la
información porque la policía no hace el
anda neutralizó a tiros al autor del
ataque terrorista en un supermercado de
la ciudad de oakland donde hirió a seis
personas con un cuchillo
la primera ministra hasina arena aseguró
que el extremista era ya conocido por
las autoridades de su país desde el año
2016 desde melbourne nuestro
corresponsal kelly brook camilo montoya
con todos los detalles
el ataque ocurrió a plena luz del día
hacia las 2 y 40 de la tarde -hora
local- de oakland en nueva zelanda este
hombre de nacionalidad decir lanka llegó
al supermercado sacó un cuchillo y atacó
a las personas inocentes que estaban
allí haciendo sus compras la policía
reaccionó y logra batirlo en menos de un
minuto de inmediato la primera ministra
de nueva zelanda ya sin darder convocó a
una conferencia de prensa y fue enfática
al decir que se trató de un ataque
terrorista de tipo individual que nada
tiene que ver con religión con culturas
o con etnias esto por supuesto para
evitar cualquier expresión de xenofobia
en nueva zelanda también dijo que este
hombre había llegado al país hace diez
años y que desde hace cinco años era
seguido de cerca por parte de la policía
pues había informaciones de que era
simpatizante del autodenominado estado
islámico y también sería sospechas de
que estaba planeando un atentado de este
tipo incluso estuvo bajo arresto pero
fue dejado en libertad por falta de
evidencia también hay una orden de la
corte que les impide a las autoridades
revelar por ahora su identidad pero ya
se está solicitando a la corte que
retire esta medida para que nueva
zelanda le pueda contar la identidad de
este atacante
44 muertos deja el paso de aida por el
noreste de eeuu los estados de nueva
york y nueva jersey resultaron
seriamente afectados por las lluvias
torrenciales inundaciones repentinas e
históricas el panorama es devastador
después de la tormenta desde el sur al
norte de eeuu el presidente yo vaya en
viajará este viernes para conocer de
primera mano la destrucción
mario rodríguez vuelve a su trabajo por
primera vez después del paso del huracán
aid a su taller de reparación de
automóviles está totalmente sumergido su
historia es la misma de miles de
habitantes en el estado de nueva york
tengo tres niños una niña y un buen
trabajo es todo lo que quería en la vida
era mi sueño y ahora tengo la impresión
de haber perdido todo pero este es
catalogado como un evento meteorológico
histórico en la gran manzana por ejemplo
se rompieron los récords registrados
hace solo unos días con las fuertes
lluvias descargadas por la tormenta
gente dejando un máximo histórico de 80
milímetros de agua sobre el central para
la nueva gobernadora del estado de nueva
york dijo que cerca de 20 millones de
habitantes podrían verse afectados
algunos kilómetros de allí en el estado
de nueva jersey la lluvia también hizo
de las suyas según el gobernador 23
personas murieron mayormente por quedar
atrapados en sus vehículos dentro de las
inundaciones
acá pocas casas están a salvo todo debe
reconstruirse
como miembro de esta comunidad puedo
asegurarles que la ampliación de las
donaciones y del apoyo que ha surgido en
el curso de las últimas horas es
simplemente increíble
en esta zona cerca de 1400 hogares
siguen sin electricidad
sus habitantes se organizan para
retornar de nuevo a la cotidianidad
aguas que todo el mundo busque noticias
sobre sus vecinos y sus familias y sus
amigos para asegurarse que van bien
nosotros seguimos nuestras encuestas en
nuestros controles en la zona impactada
por la tormenta
acting and stones al menos seis estados
de la costa fueron tocados por el
huracán desde maryland hasta connecticut
el presidente joe biden viajará a
luisiana recorrer a las comunidades más
afectadas y se reunirá con el gobernador
del estado quien le presentará una larga
lista de necesidades para la
reconstrucción
la aviación israelí lanzó un nuevo
ataque sobre siria al bombardear varios
objetivos de los alrededores de damasco
según lo confirmaron fuentes oficiales
sirias esto en medio de una nueva noche
de disturbios en la frontera de la
franja de gaza que culminaron con
violentos enfrentamientos dejando un
país y uno muerto y 15 heridos por las
fuerzas de seguridad de israel marina
sardenya con la información
neumáticos ardiendo a lo largo de la
frontera entre israel y la franja de
gaza- las protestas en contra del
bloqueo israelí sobre el sitiado enclave
volvieron a derivar en violencia con el
lanzamiento de granadas aturdidoras y
gases lacrimógenos para disuadir a los
cientos de congregados un joven
palestino murió por disparos del
ejército israelí y hay más de 15 heridos
entre ellos varios menores de edad
estábamos cerca de la frontera quemamos
algunos neumáticos mis primos estaban
conmigo nos dispararon gas lacrimógeno
hasta ahora nos están lanzando gases
lacrimógenos y me ahogue debido al gas
pero volveré de nuevo el gas hard ya se
trata de la sexta noche consecutiva de
manifestaciones lideradas por el grupo
unidad de confusión nocturna afín a
hamás las fuerzas de seguridad de israel
justificaron el uso de munición real
alegando que los manifestantes estaban
lanzando artefactos explosivos israel
mantiene a los más de 2 millones de
palestinos que viven en gaza bajo el
bloqueo desde que el grupo hamas se hizo
con el control del territorio en 2007 y
si bien israel aprobó el miércoles una
serie de medidas para aliviar las
restricciones a la franja como la
reapertura del único cruce comercial
kerem shalom para muchos nada ha
cambiado
todas las facilidades que israel dice
haber concedido a la franja de gaza
existían antes de la reciente guerra el
número de comerciantes que van a israel
antes del último conflicto era de 7000
hoy tres meses después de la guerra
israel establece ese número a siete mil
vidas raíz de los desmanes en la
frontera recuerdan a las masivas marchas
de 2018 cuando los gazatíes iniciaron un
movimiento de protesta para exigir el
fin de la asfixia económica de rally y
el derecho de los palestinos a regresar
a sus tierras
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo en france24 continuar con
nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias muy buen día
[Música]
ya de civil siguiente